a student builds a circuit with a
battery and two resistors in series the
resistance of r2 is double the
resistance of r1 below is the graph of
the energy lost at r1 over time so
that's this graph which of the following
shows the energy lost at r2 over time in
terms of e1 and we have these four
choices here so pause this video and see
if you can figure it out on your own
alright now let's do this together so
first let's visualize the circuit so you
have your a voltage source
it's our battery here so it's a positive
terminal negative terminal and then this
could be our first resistor and then
that's our second resistor they tell us
that these two resistors are in series
and we complete the circuit here this is
going to be r1 this is r2 and then if
you just have one circuit like this
where you don't have any parts of it
that are in parallel your current
throughout this circuit is going to be
constant so we could say at any point
here our current let's just call that I
now they tell us how these resistances
relate to each other if r1 has a
resistance of let's call it X ohms they
tell us that the resistance of r2 is
double the resistance of r1 so this is X
ohms this is going to be 2x ohms and
then to think about what would be if
this is the energy dissipated across r1
over time to think about the energy
dissipated across r2 over time let's
think about power and energy and what we
know about them so we know that power is
equal to energy dissipated over time so
we could write for example power is
equal to energy dissipated over time
which can be expressed as your change in
voltage across a resistor times the
current going through that resistor and
so if you want an expression for energy
dissipated over time you can look at
this part right over there we can just
multiply both sides by delta T and so we
could write that energy dissipated over
time is going to be equal to our change
in voltage across the
resistor times the current going through
the resistor times the art change in
time now if we are starting at time
equals zero our change in time is just
going to be whatever time we are at
minus zero so it's going to be whatever
time we're at so I'm just gonna write
times T right over here now your change
in voltage across a resistor we have
learned before your change in voltage
across a resistor is just going to be
the current going through that resistor
times the resistance so we could take
this and substitute it back for Delta V
and what do we get we get energy
dissipated is going to be equal to our
current going through a resistor times
the resistance times the current going
through the resistor times time or we
could write that energy dissipated as a
function of well as a function of all
three of these things is going to be the
current squared times the resistance
times time now we already know from this
that at time T one we have an energy
dissipated of e1 and that's what the
resistance of X ohms so we can say we
have energy dissipated of e1 is equal to
I squared times X ohms that's the
resistance times t1 but now let's think
about what the energy dissipated at time
T sub one for our second resistor would
be at the energy dissipated if we just
go back to this equation right over here
is going to be equal to T sub one times
our current remember we have the same
current going through both resistors
there in series so we have the same
current there I squared and then what is
going to be the resistance well instead
of an X we have a 2x here and so we can
rewrite this we could rewrite this as
two times I squared times X times t1
well this right over here is the same
thing as the amount of energy dissipated
at time T sub one in our first resistor
so this is e sub one so
time T sub-1 the energy dissipated in
our second resistor is going to be twice
as much energy and so what we want to
look at is at time T sub one we want to
have twice as much energy this
dissipated this only has 1/4 as much so
we rule that out this says half as much
energy dissipated rule that out this has
the same amount of energy to dissipated
we rule that out but then here at time T
sub one we have dissipated twice as much
energy so we like that choice right over
there another way to think about it is
if you have the same current going
through two resistors and the second
resistor has twice the resistance in any
given amount of time for the second
resistor you're going to dissipate twice
as much energy another way think about
you'll have twice the slope of this line
so this one right over here clearly has
twice the slope of this or you could say
for any given amount of time so from
time equals zero to T sub one you would
dissipate twice as much energy so
instead of e sub one you would dissipate
two times e sub one